[Music]
good afternoon it's a privilege for me
to welcome you here today once again for
the Institute's ninth annual Memorial
observance honoring the Reverend dr.
Martin Luther King jr. we come together
each year at this season to honor this
great leader for the lessons he taught
us about justice and injustice about
human values and human relations it
seems to me that we need now more than
ever to pay heed to those lessons why
now more than ever
perhaps this sense comes from events in
the life of my own family and in the
life of this institution during this
past year for my family this year marked
the arrival of a new generation our
first grandchild
Hannah was born every birthday indeed
every coming of life into this world is
an occasion for dreams when this first
child of our first child was born I
could not help but think about and hope
for the world which she is entering and
into which she will grow and today I
cannot help but think of Martin Luther
King's hopes for his own small children
hopes he expressed in that historic
moment 20 years ago when he stood before
the Lincoln Memorial and said I have a
dream I have a dream that my four little
children well one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character who among us
not wish for a future based on the
quality of the inner person rather than
on the power of a culture which Accords
so much opportunity security and
privilege on the basis of race or color
or gender or religion and who among us
would not wish for our children for our
grandchildren for ourselves a peaceful
world one in which all individuals are
accorded a full measure of their
humanity one in which a recognition of
our common condition leads us to care
for each other in a spirit of decency
and dignity and mutual respect and yet I
look at our society today
indeed I look at our community here at
MIT and sometimes I wonder I wonder when
we will realize King's dream of a world
in which all of God's children black and
white Jew and Gentile Protestant and
Catholic will be able to join hands and
walk together as sisters and his
brothers it has been 20 years since the
march on Washington on the whole I
believe conditions are better but social
justice is a fragile thing these are
difficult times times of economic and
political retrenchment times when people
are more likely to build walls than they
are to build bridges and as
opportunities in the larger society
seemed to dim many people look to the
universities to the churches to the
other private institutions in our
society to do more to be more at the
same time places like MIT have not
escaped the economic forces which limit
our
horizons and our grasp forces which
require us to cut back on programs and
plans neither have we escaped the
tensions and the fears that accompany
hard times this year has certainly been
a witness to that we cannot however use
economic conditions to justify meanness
of spirit nor can we blame all difficult
decisions on assumptions of ill will in
the months ahead as we make choices
about the kind of institution we want to
be and can be we need to build bridges
not walls among the people and the
programs of MIT our future strength as
an institution our future strength as
individuals will depend upon our ability
to remain true to our common calling and
purpose on our ability to nurture the
forces of creativity and cooperation
which give life and vigor to this
community now more than ever we need to
rekindle the spirit of Martin Luther
King for our children for our
grandchildren for ourselves yes friends
even for ourselves
Thank You dr. Bray for your warm welcome
and your timely remarks again I welcome
you to the ninth annual observance
honoring the Reverend dr. Martin Luther
King my name is Margaret Daniels Tyler
and it is my pleasure to serve as your
mistress of ceremonies today we have
planned what we hope to be a
thought-provoking program in remembrance
of dr. King and we hope that you will
leave with enlightened and renewed
spirit we will now have our invocation
from the Reverend dr. Leroy Adil's
minister of st. Paul's AME Church here
in Cambridge may we stand
let's bow our heads eternal God our
Father we thank you for this day we
praise thee we glorify thee we give
thanks to thee we thank you for this
occasion that we have been able to
assemble we thank you for the memories
of one of thy great warriors who afford
a good fight of faith who exemplify your
precepts in his lives and shared it with
so many we thank you for the brave
individuals who fought and stood for
freedom during that period we thank you
for allowing him to come through our
myths and touch our lives we thank you
for those today who stand for freedom
and justice for all
we pray for courage that we will stand
firm on that precepts that we are truly
our brothers keepers we pray this day
that the events that will transpire and
have transpired will be a reminder that
we should continue to fulfill those
dreams that we learned about that we've
read about that will bring brothers of
all colors and races together bless what
we do here and that we may continue to
be strong in serving thee through our
Lord Jesus Christ we pray amen
Thank You revin Adil's our hope our
future as always rest in the hopes
dreams and aspiration of our youth
please welcome mr. Ralph Davis a senior
at Newton North High School this poem is
our weary blues by Langston Hughes
droning a drowsy syncopated tune rocking
back and forth to a mellow croon I heard
a Negro play
Donald Lankes Avenue the other night by
the pale doll Paula of an old gasps like
he did a lazy sway he did a lazy swing
to the sound of those weary blues or
this ebony hands on each ivory key he
made that poor piano moan with melody Oh
blues swaying to and fro on his rickety
stool he played that sad raggy tune like
a musical fool sweet blues coming from a
black man so Oh blows well in a deep
song voice with a melancholy tone I
heard that off saying that Oh
piano Mon ain't got nobody you know this
world ain't got nobody but myself I was
going quit by frowning and putting my
troubles on the show some thump thump
when his foot on the floor he played a
few chords then he sing some more I got
the weary blues and I can't be satisfied
I got the rebbe blues and I can't be
satisfied I ain't happy no I wish I had
well fall into the night he crude this
tune the Stars went out and so did the
moon
the singer stopped playing and went to
bed while the weary blues echo drown in
his head he slept like a rock
or man that's dead
Thank You mr. Davis I know that most of
you are familiar with mr. Nelson
Armstrong associate director of
admissions here at MIT
Nell's as we affectionately call him
will now introduce our keynote speaker
the Honorable a Leon Higginbotham
good afternoon all I had originally
intended today to try to paint a picture
of a man that was a very learning and
educated man
I thought maybe I would come up here and
talk about the fact that he had
graduated from Yale Law School and
talked about what he had done at Antioch
I thought maybe I would come up here and
talk about all the different honorary
degrees this young man has because they
told us something like 16 I thought that
that would give us a chance to see that
we had more than just a qualified person
to be standing up here talking to us but
it didn't quite do the trick for me so I
decided maybe that's not the picture
that I really want to paint I thought
maybe I should paint the picture of a
person who was responsible for educating
others to talk about the students that
work with him be they his pages be they
the students that he's had a chance to
be in touch with across the country
everywhere to say things to how he
educated us when he came here this past
June but I wasn't so sure that was the
right kind of message to deliver either
so then I decided let me come up here
and paint a picture of a man who's been
involved in all kinds of civil rights
through his life who's been involved in
the legal system here who's been right
there on the front line all the time to
help us out to make sure that the kinds
of things that needed to happen were
happening and I'm sure sometimes he had
great success and sometimes he faced
failure but that wasn't quite enough
either so today I decided why I get up
and talk all kinds of things and draw
all kinds of pictures to make sure that
we knew exactly who we were he was
prepared to do that himself and the very
best thing that I could do as I stood
here was to make sure the child knew
that here we had a friend he was a man
that was prepared to come and spend some
time with us to share with us his
knowledge to share with us his
experiences and so forth so I'll
introduce to some of some of you who may
have never seen him before and I'll
present to you that educator that
learned it man that man that has had
that experience and so forth that man
that's prepared to share with us to
counter things that he's lived
may I introduced to you and present to
you judge Leon Higginbotham
[Applause]
dr. and mrs. dry mr. Armstrong mr. Tyler
mr. Davis
reven at leas ladies and gentlemen and
Friends of the MIT family I wanted to
mention one other name
Dean Turner well I understand that he
recently had a heart attack and I wanted
to make sure that you would say to him
of my high esteem of him handling the
very very difficult problems of bringing
justice whether it is in our court
system or in our city government federal
government or university certainly
carries with it an extraordinary amount
of wear and tear
I guess what has become so obvious to me
that so often it is not recognized those
who have the commitment whose names will
not go down history the way Martin
Luther King's name has appropriately
often have been going on with the kind
of internal intensity to bring about a
better world and I would like for Dean
Turner to know that I consider him one
of the profiles and courage in American
higher education and I extend to have my
very best wishes of course it is for me
a high honor to speak about a person
whose contributions to our nation and
world are so significant and meaningful
for whom I like you will always have the
highest esteem admiration and respect
dr. Williams suggested to me that your
theme of today was rekindling the spirit
of Martin Luther King and a time of
retrenchment
and that theme recognizes that we must
first comprehend the spirit and the
significance of Martin Luther King's
contributions it forces us to recognize
that certainly in our land we are
experiencing apathetic retrenchment from
the goals which Martin Luther King spoke
for and worked for and even died for and
hopefully by the very nature of your
theme and the continuance of these
lectures to the ninth year you are
expressing a firm commitment to not only
rekindle the spirit but to translate
that spirit in terms of solid
accomplishments and the lives of the
citizens in our nation and world this
King would have urged us as we pay honor
to Martin Luther King today it was
essential that we not become enamored
with ritual or celebrations that have no
relationship to the responsibilities and
commitment that King continually
reminded us of and prodded us to accept
the support of a Martin Luther King
lectureship or even a Martin Luther King
holiday will become an empty act if the
supporters are merely applauding King
now that he is dead we must as your
president suggested make a commitment to
implement King's goals for those still
living in our nation and world were too
many continue to endure far too much
injustice and deprivation Abraham
Lincoln in 1855 gave some thought to the
4th of July and as he started to speak
of the 4th of July he said
when we were political slaves of King
George and wanted to be free we call the
maxim that all men are created equal a
self-evident truth but now when we have
grown fat and have lost all dread of
being slaves ourselves we've become so
greedy to be masters that we call the
same Maxim a self-evident law and he
concluded by saying the fourth of July
has not quite gruntled away it is still
a great day for burning firecrackers and
maybe that's what our fourth of July
appears to be most of all these days
with seldom any pause for reflection
with almost never any reaffirmation of
our desire for certain national goals
and that could be one of the great
tragedies on Martin Luther King's
birthday that we could become so
insensitive that is Abraham Lincoln said
of the 4th of July that it will become a
day which is almost a self-evident lie
so how is it that we can keep the spirit
of Martin Luther King rekindled it
appears that particularly at a
university we have to recognize what a
heroic figure he was at the very least I
submit to you that if the High Court of
history had to evaluate him
they would put him at a level reserved
for only a few highly revered leaders
such as George Washington Thomas
Jefferson Abraham Lincoln Franklin
Roosevelt and John Fitzgerald Kennedy
but yet I submit to you that in that
judgment role it should probably place
Martin Luther King one level higher for
King did not have soldiers armed with
rifles
as did George Washington he did not
write a tease from his study as did
Jefferson one of Kings most eloquent
expressions was a letter written from a
Birmingham jail
and King did not have the massive
resources of the federal government as
did presidents Roosevelt Kennedy and
Johnson and yet despite the shortage of
staff despite his inability to command
governments or armies Martin Luther King
was able to inspire to prod and to
encourage Americans to move from a
valley of despair towards as he would
phrase it a mountaintop of Hope and
through the moral strength and eloquence
of his arguments he caused state
governments to surrender their position
of nullification and to repudiated their
pledge to segregation forever he
motivated presidents senators and
congressmen faculty and students he won
the Nobel Peace Prize though in an
official capacity he had little to do
with Foreign Affairs he was a legend and
a prophet of our time not merely for
blacks not merely for America but for
the entire world so what is the danger
when someone has left us such an
extraordinary legacy the danger is that
he will be forgotten or underestimated
and many Americans will never know of
the Montgomery bus boycott of the
bombing of the children in Birmingham
Alabama or the March and Selma of the
August 1963 march on Washington of the
slaying and burial of three civil rights
workers in Philadelphia Mississippi and
maybe some will not know even of King's
assassination on April 4th yet these
events are for blacks and for all
Americans who care as sacred as our
Valley Forge kings walk from Selma to
Montgomery was as significant as George
Washington's advance across the Delaware
King speech at the march on Washington
was as moving as Lincoln's and gutters
for King's letter from a Birmingham jail
was as profound as anything that Thomas
Jefferson ever wrote but the danger is
with the current generation may perceive
of helm solely as a dreamer and that
would be the most tragic distortion of
all because King was both a dreamer but
most important and activists his
greatest contributions went far beyond
pure eloquence which he had in such
abundance
it was the movements he organized the
marches he led the battles he fought
which became the compelling force to
transform our nation some might suggest
that perhaps Thomas Jefferson and Martin
Luther King could or should be compared
and I'd like to spend a few minutes with
you pro being an intellectual journey
and thinking in terms of a comparison of
Thomas Jefferson was ranked as one of
our leading philosophers or leading
statesmen why would you write Thomas
Jefferson so high what would you say was
Thomas Jefferson's most important
writing some might say it was the
Declaration of Independence others might
say it was the Declaration of the causes
and necessities and taking up arms and
others might say it was his
extraordinary inaugural address but if
you want to compare Thomas Jefferson
with Martin Luther King let me submit to
you what at least one person Sandi would
say was Thomas Jefferson's most
important writing he said and wrote this
advertisement which appeared in the
Virginia Gazette run away from the
subscriber and album all a mulatto slave
called Sandy about 35 years of age
his stature is rather loud inclining to
corpulence and for your English
professors I know you will be delighted
that even when Tom Jefferson wrote a
slave advertisement he brought to it
such great style
he said his stature is rather low
inclining to corpulence and Yale we
would have said he was short and fat but
how did Thomas Jefferson end up this is
extraordinary virtus man had said
whoever conveys the said slave to me in
a broom all shall have forty shillings
reward if taken up within the county
four pounds of elsewhere within the
colony and ten pounds if in any other
colony and thus Thomas Jefferson by this
very very advertisement was repudiating
the Equality of men which he had lauded
as a self-evident truth of the
Declaration of Independence and how can
one put Jefferson and Martin Luther King
in the same context I don't know any way
in which I could suggest a medium in
which you could explore it of anything
you have at MIT I would have to go back
to a place which may not be recognized
by your Department of astronomy I grew
up in a fundamentalist Baptist Church
where we heard endless sermons on heaven
as some lofty galaxy where all God's
children would someday meet and thus I
ask you for the purposes of this lecture
to give me your imagination and imagine
for a moment that there is a heaven and
imagine that for a moment you have the
opportunity to eavesdrop on a
conversation which takes place between
Thomas Jefferson and Martin Luther King
the conversation proceeds as follows
Martin Luther King has just read this
advertisement on sandy he starts to talk
to Thomas Jefferson as follows mr.
Jefferson
now but we're here in heaven where
there's no reward for evasiveness and
we're immoral conduct will not be
tolerated
please tell me mr. Jefferson why did you
have slaves on what moral principle
could you justify that advertisement for
Sandy and on what moral precept could
you justify your ownership of hundreds
of other slaves
mr. Jefferson how could you defend the
institution of slavery with all of its
pernicious consequence
how could you condone a system and which
individuals were subjected to lifetime
servitude knowing that their children
and their children's children would
suffer the same fate in fact mr.
Jefferson since you were the leader of
our country let me read to you two other
advertisements which were typical of
thousands which appeared in your
newspapers throughout the nation how for
the society which had pledged to the
Justice of the Declaration of
Independence tolerant such let me read
to you perhaps only one Negroes for sale
a negro woman 24 years of age and her
two children one eight and the other
three years old said Negroes will be
sold separately or together as desired
the woman is a good seamstress she'll be
sold loafer cash or exchange for
groceries four terms apply to matthew
bliss and company mr. Jefferson how
could you have created a society where a
woman who had harmed no one who had
punished no one could have the child
which she had brought into this world
taken away from her and sold
just the way you sold beer tobacco and
you solved your carton on what concept
do you explain the type of society which
you have in fact mr. Jefferson since we
have such equality here do you mind if I
call you Tom
now Tom how is it that individuals who
were as philosophical and as profound as
you men as brave as George Washington
and his eloquent as Patrick Henry could
treat an entire group of people with
such special harshness and cruelty
solely because of their skins and I
would imagine Martin Luther King
concluding perhaps after pausing for
some tea Tom I did not intend for my
comments to be construed as a diatribe
against you but since as a leader our
schoolchildren give you so much credit
for so many of the significant
accomplishments of our country I submit
to you you must share part of the blame
what is a nation we failed to be as
humane as we should have been I've been
talking nonstop Tom what is your answer
and I would imagine that Thomas
Jefferson as a thoughtful lawyer if you
can imagine any lawyers in heaven my
first try to answer King's question by
relying on precedent and quoting from
scholarly treatises I would submit to
you that Thomas Jefferson would say
Martin your question disturbs me as I
see all of the cruelty which was
perpetuated for two centuries two and a
half centuries after our Declaration of
Independence
it is not justifiable as you may recall
that when I wrote my notes on Virginia I
included this slide when looking at the
issue of slavery
I said indeed I tremble for my country
when I reflect that God is just but as
justice cannot sleep forever and I will
save the continuation of an imaginary
sampling of heavenly dialogue between
Thomas Jefferson and Martin Luther King
for another occasion but I've used this
as an example to raise something which
is fundamental as to what can happen in
a nation and what is it that 1776
reveals most dramatically it reveals
that leaders who are even supposed to be
good people may protect the options for
80% of the people while at the same time
they perpetuate a system that is
oppressive and destructive to the other
20% and that is what occurred in our
Revolutionary period justice for most
whites and gross injustice for all
blocks and as to the 20% of our society
who can be forgotten as they were
forgotten in those days the same thing
can happen and I submit to you is
happening in the 1980s and it is
essential today more so than ever before
that Americans understand the breadth
and the importance of Martin Luther
King's concerns concerns which dealt
with the failures that Thomas Jefferson
was not able to cope with or did not
cope
though in speech after speech King made
reference to the ugly villain of racism
never forget that he focused on jobs
housing education health care poverty
and hunger does this nation want to
implement dr. King's dream if so I
submit to you we do not carry forward
Martin Luther King's dream if we applaud
him while simultaneously cutting off
food stamps for the truly poor we do not
carry forward dr. Martin Luther King's
dream if we leave our cities so
destitute of funds that the aged cannot
get housing and deprived children can
get neither adequate substance nor
quality education we do not carry
forward Martin Luther King's dream if we
adopt tax policies which tolerate or
even encourage racism and hatred we do
not carry forward Martin Luther King's
dream if the poor feel alienated and
perceive those in powers as insensitive
to the plight of the weak and the
dispossessed to bridge the gap from
Thomas Jefferson's unfinished task to
Martin Luther King's dreams mean
increasing Lee that all of us must focus
on the functioning of the economic
mechanisms in our society we must enter
the dialogue as to how national
resources are used and how national
state and local budgets are allocated we
must study with care as to how much is
spent on defense to thought enemies
abroad and how much is spent to deter
poverty disease and despair are
crippling enemies at home we do not
carry forward Martin Luther King's dream
if we applaud his dream and remain
silent while diatribes on race our
espoused all around us just as we make
judgments on events surrounding
Jefferson and his contemporaries 200
years ago our generation
we'll be evaluated and they will ask
questions of the 1980s which will not
apply solely to race will probe deeply
on the options of the weak the poor and
the dispossessed what values and
priorities will they find that we now
have in our nation what will be the
blind spots and the gaps will it be the
irony that in a nation of high
educational achievement and many fine
colleges and superb universities such as
MIT the millions of children receive an
adequate public school education will be
the contradiction that in a nation which
in 1954 proclaimed that separate was not
equal the nevertheless twenty nine years
later we have so much de facto
segregation will it be the fact that a
nation which landed a man safely on the
moon and often sent space shuttles into
orbit cannot create viable jobs for
millions of a citizens who seek a better
life will it be the paradox that a
nation with the highest standard of
living still has 25 million persons
living below the poverty level and the
high court of history will ask questions
about MIT every time I visit this
marvelous campus I'm overwhelmed by your
past and present contributions to the
development of existing and new
technologies mit stands almost alone as
a symbol of the highest excellence in
science and America and in the world
it's impressive to note that five
present members of your faculty by Nobel
laureates in Physiology and medicine in
economics and physics
but please remember that we meet here
today to honor a person who did not earn
his Nobel laureate for any discoveries
in the laboratories of academia he
earned his for the human values he
pursued for the human values he
advocated and for the non violent
confrontations he led in order to bring
more justice in America and thus
notwithstanding the technological
excellence achieved on this great MIT
campus we must always remember the
technological excellence will never be
and has never been per se the equivalent
of human values and pursuing his gold
Martin Luther King was not aided by mi
t--'s radiation laboratories
extraordinary breakthroughs in the
development of microwave radar his
fundamental social justice concerns were
not solved in any of your laboratories
or advanced by any of your computers dr.
King recognized that education and
technological excellence was important
but it did not mean that it would be
translated into social justice of the
speech which your president has
commented two sections below his
reference to his children Martin Luther
King said I have a dream that one day
the state of Alabama whose governor's
lips are presently dripping with the
words of interposition and nullification
will be transformed into a situation
where little black boys and black girls
will be able to join hands with little
white boys and white girls and walk
together as sisters and brothers
who was it who help blacks and whites in
Alabama too late a walk together in
greater harmony and who was it who made
possible for blacks and whites to
compete almost as if they were brothers
even on the football fields of the
university of alabama certainly it was
not mi t--'s efforts to harness
thermonuclear fusion in your al qaeda
project it was the march on Washington
the civil rights protests the civil
rights litigation king's confrontation
with governor Wallace and the political
and financial efforts of millions that
made such a critical difference we must
not forget that King's great
contribution was not a contribution
which merely helped blacks it helped all
minorities and perhaps as one studies
the 1960 first Civil Rights Act and I've
been a federal judge down for 19 years
perhaps women have been helped more than
any other group because of the 1964
Civil Rights Act and if you doubt it
look over the data the march on
Washington and the ultimate passage of
the 1964 Civil Rights Act transmitted a
warning signal telling America to
provide more social justice in our land
and these higher new levels which these
statutes made possible were unaffected
by even the hurtling efforts at the
Lincoln laboratories and developing the
distant early warning system the
semi-automatic ground environment
projects and your experimental
satellites which have been thrust into
outer space
I admire your mastery of devices to
determine the physical properties of
molecules such as viscosity thermal
conductivity
and diffusion coefficients your
leadership and these technologies must
continue but we must never forget that
despite your increasing mastery of
science the weak and the poor in this
country can end up as excluded from the
current American mainstream as slaves
were excluded from the benefits of
Thomas Jefferson's egalitarian teaching
the Declaration of Independence and thus
if we wish to develop the proper
coefficients of true social justice in
America we must have a fusion a fusion
of Martin Luther King's dream with mi
t--'s symbolic superior technology last
week the distinguished president of
Tufts dr. Jean mayor said sample
economic calculations show there's a
growing number of people who cannot
literally afford what nutritionists
consider to be a minimum diet he went on
to say of all the foolish ways to save
money not to feed people particularly at
a time and we have food surpluses coming
out of our ears nationally seems to be
one of the most short-sighted if dr.
Mayer is correct and I believe he is and
if we are in a period of retrenchment
which I think we are what would dr. King
say to us today if he could speak what
would he say to the scholars the faculty
the administrators and the students of
MIT and to our nation he would want us
to understand what I think many don't
that in his view integration alone was
never enough he was not interested in
integrated hunger he was not entered
interested and integrated poverty he was
not interested and integrated
unemployment and he was not interested
in integrated crime
what would he ask you I think he would
say thinking of doctor mayor's remarks
what is the value of superior technology
if we can produce big agricultural
surpluses and still the poor needlessly
starve or suffer malnutrition I think
that he'd ask you what is the worth of
superior technology as we expand our
industrial capacity of people who
desperately want to work cannot get jobs
I think that he would ask you what is
the value of superior technology if
children can't get quality education in
elementary school and junior high school
and in high school he would ask you to
reflect on the last sermon he preached
at Ebenezer Baptist Church most of you
have heard it where he said if any of
you around when I have to meet my day I
don't want a long funeral if you get
somebody to deliver the eulogy tell them
not to talk too long tell them not to
mention that I have a Nobel Peace Prize
that isn't important tell them not to
mention that I have three or four
hundred awards that's not important
tell them not to mention where I went to
school I like somebody to mention that
day that Martin Luther King tried to
give his life serving others I like for
somebody to say that day Martin Luther
King tried to love somebody I tried to
be right on the war question I want you
to be able to say that day I did try to
feed the hungry I want you to be able to
say that day I did try in my life to
clothe those who were naked I want you
to say on that day I did try in my life
to visit those who were in prison
I want you to say I tried to love and
service humanity these are the critical
issues on which we must focus if we
truly want to rekindle the spirit and
Martin Luther King symbolize he would
want us to focus on love peace hunger
and jobs rather than simply honoring him
today he would want us to improve the
standards of justice and our courts our
legislature our city halls our state
houses and the White House he would want
us to recognize than verbal platitudes
on justice and equality are at best
deceptions and at worse even venal
if we are not committed to provide and
assure justice and equality for all
how will we in our generation as
individuals and in our institutions
respond to the retrenchment well we have
the courage to seek the truth and to
speak out against those practices that
fall short of our our ideals well
history be able to say of us that
because of our values and priorities the
poor the disadvantaged and the weak were
needlessly harmed denigrated and ignored
or will historians be able to say the
because of our priorities and values we
understood and strove as valiantly as we
could to achieve the kind of world
Martin Luther King envisioned when he
said I have the audacity to believe that
people everywhere can have three meals a
day for their bodies Education and
Culture for their minds and dignity
equality and freedom for their spirits
judge Higgenbotham thank you for sharing
with us your thoughts and insights you
are a friend and you are an inspiration
at this time mr. Kemp Harris a local
educator will inspire us with the medley
of songs
[Music]
Oh cha things are gonna get easier
Oh cha things look at bride
oh wow things are gonna get easier
Oh shall things look at brighter someday
yeah we'll get it together and we'll get
it undone someday when the world is much
brighter someday yeah walking the Rays
of a beautiful song someday when your
head is much lighter
how things are gonna get easier Oh chop
things looking brighter brighter
brighter brighter brighter things are
gonna get easier
how things will get brighter right now
right now
[Music]
there's a new
come in
and it's just around the bed
and there's a new
day dawning
this one's coming too
[Music]
[Applause]
the one that we've visions of coming in
[Music]
coming in
and coming in
[Music]
coming
things looking right
someday we'll get it together and get it
under someday
some Nick yeah we walk in the race I'm a
beautiful song someday
as much
[Music]
some things you can ride it Friday
Friday Friday Ryder chop things don't
get any easier
y'all things you can ride right now
right
[Music]
[Applause]
reach out and touch somebody
make this world a better place if you
can
reach out some make this world
if you can
take a little timeout your busy day to
give encouragement to someone who's lost
me way
well would I be talking to strong if I
to share a problem that's not your
[Music]
if you can feels here I know he'd love
it reach out and touch
[Music]
make this
if you can
if you see an over in on the street and
it's down then remember his shoes could
mean if you try a little kindness I know
that you will see something that comes
[Music]
and touch
when I just listen for a while
which are
[Music]
why don't you reach out to us
richer
some world better day
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You mr. Kemp for that soulful
rendition directly following the
benediction by Reverend adults please
join us in the mezzanine lounge at the
Stratton Student Center for a reception
to which all are welcome remember also
that the Institute is officially closed
tomorrow Friday January 15th 14th I'm
sorry in observance of the birthday of
the Reverend dr. Martin Luther King
webinars may we stand for the
benediction
our Father now god we thank you for thy
servant whom thou has sent today to
present ourselves to ourselves to show
us a new direction to bring us new
awarenesses and new hopes and new dreams
father we pray that as we depart at this
time that we no part without a burning
desire to fulfill the dreams of thy
great servant that all men ought be
brothers we pray that we may have a
burning desire for justice that would
roll down like a mighty stream now may
thy peace and joy reign among us
brotherly love and goodwill with all of
thy people hence now and forevermore
amen
you